Okay.
I want you to check this out
because it represents a big challenge
for large language models
like GPT-3...
and now GPT-4.
But it is not code.
It is a list that countries
around the world
are grappling with.
Before we get into the problems
with large language models,
let's review at a basic level...
how they work.
You've probably heard
of ChatGPT.
It's not really a model
but an app that sits on top of
a large language model.
In this case, a version
of GPT.
One thing models like ChatGPT do
is natural language processing.
It's used in everything
from telephone customer service
to auto completion.
GPT is like a used bookstore.
It's never left the room
and only learned through the books
that are at the store.
Essentially, these large language models...
they scan a lot of text and
try to learn a language.
They can check their process
by covering up the answers...
and then seeing if they got it right.
Then they can use that knowledge
to recognize sentiment...
summarize, translate
and generate responses
or recommendations
based on the analyzed data.
And yes, ChatGPT wrote
that last line.
You've got to do that
in videos like this.
This is an amazing ability
but that's because it's read
a lot of stuff.
You can ask ChatGPT
to rephrase something
to Shakespeare
but that's because it's read
all the Shakespeare
and that is where my waste of paper
comes in.
Actually, I want to show
you something.
Yeah? Good?
Okay.
So this is a print out of Common Crawl
from 2008 to the present.
Common crawl basically means that
they go over all the websites
and index them.
And on this list, they put
every language
that they think that
they've indexed.
Here, you notice right away
all the English.
Every crawl is like more than
40% just English.
German: DEU.
See the indexes here...
you know, it's about
6% every time
which doesn't sound like a lot,
but it's kind of a lot.
But look here, 2023.
FIN: Finnish. Lot of pages.
But it's just 0.4% of the entire scan.
This bookstore, it's got
an inventory problem.
All of the focus is on only
a very small set of languages.
There was a paper that stated that
of the 7,000 languages spoken globally
about 20 of those languages
make up the bulk of NLP research.
Okay, so let's back up a bit.
This is Ruth-Ann Armstrong.
She's a researcher who I interviewed
and she's doing something
that a lot of researchers
are trying to do...
make new data sets.
Those 20 languages fall into
our category called
high-resource languages
and the others fall
into a category
called low-resource languages.
Those low-resource languages
don't show up on the Internet
as text as much
which means they don't make it
into language datasets.
They become unintelligible
to the AI.
Imagine our used bookstore again.
It has a ton of Dan Brown books
or James Patterson
or Anne Tyler.
This is like English and German
and Chinese.
The high-resource languages.
Then there are the rare books.
These are the low-resource languages.
So, many models just don't know
as much about them...
or have anything at all.
I’m someone from Jamaica.
The language primarily spoken
in Jamaica is English...
but we also speak a Creole language
called Jamaican patois.
Armstrong and her coauthors wanted
to create a dataset
that can explain this largely
spoken language
but they weren't trying to generate
texts like ChatGPT.
Instead, they wanted their model
to understand it.
In this case, to do that,
Armstrong went through
a bunch of examples of Jamaican patois
and lined them up.
Two columns.
And she labeled whether the statements
entailed or agreed, contradicted,
or were neutral.
You can try it
in this one.
A has a fever.
B has a high temperature.
So it’s entailment.
They agree.
Try this one: Entailment
or contradiciton?
Contradiction.
One more.
Neutral.
The two statements
don't really relate.
She did that for almost
650 examples.
You can probably see that
this was a ton of work.
And Jamaican patois is not on
my big list of
Common Crawl languages.
I also talked to some Catalan researchers...
who are trying to evaluate how well
these big language models
do on stuff like Catalan.
It is the most spoken in this
autonomous community of Spain.
In GPT-3, the percentage
of English words is 92%.
For German, there's 1.4% words.
Spanish appears in 0.7%.
And finally, Catalan.
The amount of Catalan words in
the whole training set is 0.01%.
And it still performs very, very well.
So the problem here is
a little bit different, right?
They've got some Catalan
in the dataset.
Common Crawl says Catalan is
0.2335% of their survey.
Not a lot, but some.
In the big company models like GPT-3
and presumably GPT-4 in the future
were proven to do pretty well
on little data.
For example, the research team
got GPT-3
to generate 3 Catalan sentences.
And then they mixed them up
with real sentences.
Three native speakers
then evaluated them.
So, that was our test.
And their results were very good
for the machine.
But there is still a catch.
It performs reasonably well.
But it's worth it to build
a language-specific model
that has been specifically trained
and evaluated for that language.
So the problem here
isn't performance
it’s transparency and
it's the amount of data.
I mean, Common Crawl says
that they indexed...
millions of examples
of Catalan words.
But GPT-3 says that they only read
about 140 pages of Catalan.
Imagine like a novella.
It's a problem being dependent
on the performance or
even the goodwill
of a few institutions or
a few companies.
You can easily imagine a world where
one of these companies
just cuts out Catalan.
The same way Catalan News complained
Google was cutting out
Catalan links in searches.
Common Crawl is just
a percent of what
GPT-3 was trained for.
We don't know the details
about GPT-4.
And that means a lot of other stuff
went into this language model that
we just don't know about.
Right now all these bookstores
are actually run by
Meta or Microsoft or Baidu
or Open AI or Google.
They decide which books
go in there
and don't tell anyone where they came from
or who wrote them.
Some people are trying
to build a library
next to the bookstore.
This is Paris, where the French
have a supercomputer
that wasn't being used a lot.
It’s like almost down the road
and I was discussing with the people...
who built it and they're like,
“Nobody uses this GPU.”
Basically, what can we do?
Thomas Wolf is a co-founder
of Hugging Face
which is like a hub for AI research
on the Internet
and they ended up working
on Big Science’s BLOOM...
a project to create an open-source
multilingual model.
And the more we thought about it
we thought it's also a lot better,
in fact, that we trained it
in a lot of other languages,
not just English.
And if we try to involve
many people
and so it started from a small
Hugging Face project
to become a very big collaboration.
Where we tried to open this
to everyone.
They basically went down
the Wikipedia list
of most spoken languages
and covered those.
But also added low-resource languages
when possible.
So we have very, very low-resource
languages there.
Mostly in African languages.
And so here to gather
the data there
what we decided was to partner
as much as possible with
local communities
and ask them basically what they thought
were good data
and how we could get it.
As importantly, we know where
the data comes from
and how it was obtained.
That's the difference in open-source.
You know the books in the library.
All right, let me find English.
Okay, so let's being honest
as an English speaker...
I'm kind of the target audience
for these big companies
in these big models.
English represents
more than 40% of the
Common Crawl
but there are reasons for even
the target audience
to want all languages to be
well represented.
I am an English speaker but
I have my Jamaican accent
and I remember that...
initially like when Siri came out,
I had a harder time using it
because it couldn't understand
my accent.
So expanding even
the training dataset
for voice assistants include...
more accents has been helpful.
So imagine what would happen
if we tried to expand
another piece of that.
We're building technologies for
more languages as well.
So if you want to have
this model everywhere
you need to be able
to trust them.
So if you trust Microsoft,
that's fine.
But if you don't trust them...
yeah.
It's our language.
So we speak— we are
Catalan speakers.
So whereas because of
a small language
or of a moderately
small language
because you may have languages
that have a...
a sizable amount of speakers
in the real world
but that have very, very little
digital footprint.
So they are bound to just...
disappear.